okay so since I've been in quarantine I
haven't really been able to hang out
with people so I decided to dust off my
trusty robot and hang out with her
because she hasn't been anywhere ever
she lives in a box in my attic it's more
of a coffin but I realized when I took
her out that I cut my hair and we
haven't cut her hair to match me so I
should probably use this time at home to
cut her hair
absolutely not Wiggly
you don't really have a choice in the
matter because you don't have arms your
legs so I'm just gonna cut it the same
length as mine like shoulder length okay
I don't really know how to cut hair but
oh how hard can it be
it's don't good don't don't just
distract me so kitty movie it's gonna
look good it looks cute on us what
are you doing I'm cutting your hair so
we look alike okay looks good huh cute
okay stop it
No get off me you
huge okay now you're now you're being a
dick I know you have cabin fever I get
it how dare you don't plagiarize me
don't be oh my god okay now you're just
being an look we can we can put
this on eBay or something all right put
me back on my body I am without to
you up okay well I don't know where your
body is I can't find it so we have a
problem
okay this is harder than it looks
why are you looking over there stop
making me look like you you egomaniac
okay don't don't use words you don't
understand alright ready almost done
ha you can insane you look good is cute
ah your hair lines a little well sad but
that looks cute how cute er you know
what we have to make it um
so that we match a do a little thing
like a half-up half-down little thing
okay ready
all right I'm gonna do a little scrunchy
like on the top of the head I hate you
sorry oh she has a rat double full rat
tail I'm leaving this
I'm leaving the rat tails like I can
real one has a rat down Oh Oh God
oh that's so funny to me that's your new
hair don't be bad it's okay okay